us now with more on tomorrow's summit
someone who knows an awful lot about
vladimir putin
former secretary of state mike pompeo um
mr secretary we've been friends a long
time
i don't think you would have allowed the
chinese in anchorage to lecture you
on the issue of human rights the way
they did joe biden's team
would you
no we handled things very differently
sean we were serious we were determined
we drew red lines we made clear what
american interests were
and they tried to lecture us about human
rights or all the things that got
screwed up inside of china
we would have made very clear that was
unacceptable we wouldn't listen to it
what insight can you give the american
people into putin what would you expect
if joe biden called you tonight and
asked
what do you what would you expect from
me tomorrow what would you tell him
he's going to show up loaded for bear
because the evidence of the bite
administration's actions today suggests
that'll be successful
whether it was the fact that they
re-entered the new start treaty at the
very beginning read a nuclear treaty
they re-entered we didn't ask for
anything they wanted it desperately
and we gave it up we then you talked
about vladimir putin destroying our
energy industry you should know that
vice president or president biden went
first he destroyed our energy industry
by joining the paris climate accords an
enormous
gift to vladimir putin so i expect
tomorrow president putin will press
he will see how far he can push
president biden and i hope not just in
words but in deeds
this administration is prepared to show
up to do what we did to hold russia
accountable for its malign activity
and to make clear there were red lines
nobody was tougher on china than donald
trump
and in spite it was hillary clinton that
bought the dirty russian dossier how
ironic
it was the biden family that made money
from russia not the trump family
um you know donald trump just
he he loved the opportunity to do a
joint presser with somebody
like putin or kim jong-un or whoever
whatever world leader it happened to be
does it show weakness that joe won't do
a joint presser
with vladimir because i think that's a
sign of great weakness
of course it does the fact that you're
not prepared to stand
six or eight feet from your adversary
and tell the world what it is you talked
about the things you care about why you
care about them
shows enormous weakness and sean we
shouldn't forget whether it's jeremy kim
or the ayatollah or xi jinping they're
they're watching this too
when they smell weakness when they can
sniff it the deterrence model that
american successful defense depends upon
will walk away and these folks will
drive a truck through it so
if you're not prepared to simply stand
on a podium and respond
to questions from the press that might
be asked of you that might be hard or
might be tricky
while your adversary is standing a few
feet away from you that's an enormous
sign of weakness
and you would relish the fact standing
up to him you would challenge him on
these hacks that took place
colonial pipeline or our beef industry
or meat industry in america
um if there was ever an opportunity for
you to debate vladimir putin
i don't think you'd hesitate am i wrong
no i'm in sean you come along you can be
one of the moderators they can pick one
we'll we'll get after it
wait whoa whoa slow down here this is a
good idea so wait a minute
you're willing to debate vladimir putin
i can be one of the moderators and we'll
let him choose the russian moderator
we'll do a two-hour live commercial free
debate and you'd be glad to do it
[Laughter]
sounds good anytime anywhere sean uh you
have to know who you are and you have to
know who america
is and if you're prepared to do that
that kind of debate is something one
should not shy away from
vladimir conrad it's an open invitation
mike pompeo versus you you get
you get to pick your guy i'll i'll be
on the america side i'd love that debate
he's welcome anytime he likes to call
joe out for debate
joe couldn't take him up on his offer mr
secretary thanks for being with us
appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else